de grande chaleur accable tout
l'hémisphère nord et un peu partout les
forêts s'embrase
en grèce aux limites même d'athènes une
centaine de personnes sont mortes ou
disparues dans les incendies pour les
combattre la grèce disposait d'une
douzaine de bombardiers d'eau et
l'italie lui en a prêté d'autres ces
avions sont mythiques
ils sont capables d'écoper 6000 litres
d'eau en rasant la mer ou un lac en 12
secondes pour ensuite les déverser sur
les feux en europe on les appelle les
canadairs du nom de leur fabricant
canadien dans le centre de la suède
également d'importants incendies font
rage et la france a prêté deux de ses
avions
on y connait le mois de juillet le plus
chaud depuis au moins deux siècles et
demi l'an dernier c'était au tour de la
corse de connaître de graves incendies
puis du portugal où cette année encore
on s'attend à des chaleurs torrides en
le québec a envoyé plusieurs de ces cl
415 en californie l'efficacité des
canadair en ont fait des avions de
légende à travers le monde
pourtant il n'y en a pas beaucoup un peu
plus d'une centaine et ils sont
vieillissants
d'autant plus qu'au push leur
utilisation à l'extrême bombardier a
cessé dé produire en 2015 par manque de
demander à cause des coûts élevés de
fabrication mais une firme de
colombie-britannique vrai kings de
victoria crois qu'il ya un marché
prometteur pour cet avion
surtout en europe à cause du
réchauffement climatique qui provoque
bien sûr de plus en plus de feux de
forêt la flotte est vieillissante
c'est un problème à régler d'autres
marchés s'ouvrent également à cause des
changements climatiques
donc nous prévoyons un bel avenir pour
cet avion en 2016 banking a racheté à
bombardier tous les plans et les droits
sur les cl 215 et les cl 415 l'an
dernier vrakking entreposés à calgary et
11 vieux cl-215 200 employés ont été
engagés pour les transformer en cl 415
c'est à dire qu'ils auront des
turbopropulseurs et une nouvelle
avionique une compagnie du montana
bridgeurs aerospace mettra en service
début 2000 20 les cinq premiers
appareils entièrement modernisé
le marché paraît très prometteur
actuellement le timing est très bon nous
avons la chance à la fois de fournir de
9 à 11 appareils convertis qui feront le
lien avec la nouvelle production
cette nouvelle production ce serait un
tout nouvel appareil le cl 515 construit
à partir des plantes canadair weiqing
attend une aide fédérale à l'innovation
pour mettre en place sa ligne de montage
une légende pourrait renaître
jean michel leprince a du canada mombert